welcome to this video playing a hammer
tight brown hematite what is the meaning
so what is the text thank you for your
kindness okay so let's see the ruie is
he doing something no something out of
the ordinary nothing okay it seems to
take his time even for very normal
looking moves really probably should be
three okay okay he's writing thanks for
the channel noise ok we have or I cannot
really I cannot reply to that because it
does not receive tells or playing ok so
we have a standard willow pass here with
Knight a5 the chi going variation named
after the Russian known there will be
maybe the founder in a way of Russian
chess maharshi Goren
yeah he also invented the cheek or in
defense of course to the Queens gambit
it seems that the sugar in here in the
room is stolen yeah it's it's suspending
the test of time still being played on
all levels the particular line that are
playing here with 98 and later 98 even
is mostly attributed to Rubenstein who
played it in the early 20th century
especially this maneuver with the night
to g7 and now the other night coming
from d8 to f7 his Rubenstein's trademark
in a way it's a very flexible pisem
placement where black is well mostly
setting up the defensive fortress but
the counter chances are not to be
underestimated why does some of course
somewhat better but it's nothing very
serious what is serious though that he
is thinking very long here in a in an
almost theoretical position it's one of
those cases where I can actually play
quickly because I have had this on the
board probably more than I mean I know
it's certainly a three digit figure that
I had this on the board
now the next interesting moment comes
after night f7 what you will do with the
bishop taking us normally not advised as
it gives up the dark squares okay it
seems that he wants to go for f4
nevermind after inform when I when I
capture I get the e5 square what I try
to do though is maybe activate the
bishop the bishop only seven there are
two ways to do that okay now he is
switching back to the Queen side I don't
mind that very much there are ideas now
going back to a eight okay yeah he's
some doubling on the iphone oh this is
really not a big issue he has most
pieces on the King side especially the
Knights so this kind of trades on the a
file are no problem especially
considering that you like sometimes gets
in Bishop d8 to be 6 this is what I'm
trying to do now
getting rid of the the bad bishop Oh is
allowing me to go there I expected there
should be three okay he can even maybe
play Bishop e3 interesting I know I can
play Queen a7 even if I want okay how to
increase my piece activity I can always
some allowing the trade should I trade
interesting yeah well okay i can trade
now but should I trade Queens this is
actually what I was mostly thinking of
hmm if I take off the Queen's and I
don't know can I how do I make any
progress after that I don't really want
to let's let's keep them on one idea
that that is tempting now is to get a
night to F form somehow it's not easy
down until the night of course to c5
would be nice maybe start with that at
least I'm pretty much sure to to to be
able to execute this maneuver I not sure
how I should get an ID to f4 okay should
I play be four here I guess I am come on
gaining some space
ray gets the night to see three maybe
hmm now this I'm underestimated maybe i
can i can do this attacking his g4 pond
and now i'm ready to jump to a 4 that's
that's nice i'm not sure if you should
have taken i really want I really want
to go there to a forum maybe I can place
you three here c3b takes Quincy form yup
call this this should be very very
difficult than BC Quincy for attacking
the knight and Bishop b5 maybe in
addition the night now moves i get to f
form here i am to salsa idea
hmm ok maybe here i am to to take off
with the bishop take this nut over the
bishop and then night f4 and the bishop
is hanging I really never I didn't
really look at the clock is very much
bound to lose on time check ok how to do
it now Queen to h1 would be really nice
maybe I can Queen a one or something ya
know I can I one egg here check yeah
it's got no square relight resins
cooking g4 Queen age three and there is
no square yeah now we'll play to treat
very slowly and yeah this is a very nice
position here when I get you should
absolutely try to prevent we should be
six for the time being if I get the
bishop there that's really helpful for
black and it's not so easy here for why
to suggest anything great because he has
very little potential to improve this
position and like her I can actually do
some things get the night here and so on
you saw this and here i should i should
keep the Queen's on the computer
actually points out Queen a one yeah
maybe maybe this is more more active
attacking the beep on but I didn't want
to yeah consider any Queen be six moves
just wanted to keep the Queen on yeah
and here this will step by step
improvement first the night and then
here before
this is actually even stronger yeah
that's stronger and goes here I go f5
and this is falling apart black's pieces
work together very well now and
something like this is look at this
those two nights are just fantastic
pieces yeah this is so I'm amazed though
that stockfish a gives black in three
points so there's probably something
very serious happening happening in
short order okay thanks for watching